en este vídeo quiero repasar cómo está
relacionado el ingreso total con la
elasticidad de la demanda
esto es para agarrar un poquito más de
la intuición de las ideas que vimos en
el vídeo pasado muy bien vamos a empezar
dibujando un par de ejes para poner ahí
una curva de demanda entonces de este
lado tenemos el eje el eje de precio y
de este lado tenemos el eje de cantidad
para precio y cantidad y vamos a pensar
que nuestra curva de demanda se ve más o
menos así digo no tendría por qué ser
lineal pero aquí lo estamos dibujando
por simplicidad ok entonces vamos a
tomarnos por aquí un precio 1 presión 1
entonces a éste le corresponde una
cierta cantidad 1 según lo que nos dice
en nuestra curva de demanda que está más
o menos acá y lo que comentábamos en el
vídeo pasado es que si queremos
determinar el ingreso total para este
precio y para esta cantidad lo que
tenemos que hacer es hacer la
multiplicación p 1 por como por q 1
entonces aquí el ingreso total le voy a
poner ingreso total 1 es la
multiplicación de p 1 con q1 pero eso es
lo mismo que obtener esta área de acá
esta área vale algo de este estilo muy
bien entonces qué sucede si aquí nuestra
elasticidad de la demanda elasticidad de
la demanda es mayor que 1 vamos a
preguntarnos qué sucede con el cambio de
esta área de acá conforme vamos
cambiando el precio o la cantidad
entonces déjame ponerle por aquí que
quiere decir que la elasticidad de la
demanda sea mayor que 1 entonces que la
elasticidad de la demanda sea mayor que
1 es lo mismo es lo mismo a que el valor
absoluto acuérdate todo esto es el valor
absoluto y el valor absoluto de el
cambio porcentual de la cantidad entre
el cambio porcentual del precio sea
mayor que 1 o sea podemos pasar este
cambio porcentual del precio
multiplicado para acá y entonces
tendríamos que el cambio porcentual
cambio porcentual de la cantidad le gana
al cambio porcentual del precio en valor
absoluto ahí no le puse cambio
y regresar el cambio porcentual del
precio muy bien entonces eso qué quiere
decir ya con numeritos pues más o menos
lo que quiere decir es que digamos si el
precio lo cambiamos en un 10% entonces
la cantidad la vamos a cambiar en más
que 10% que sucede pues usualmente casi
siempre lo que va a suceder es que esto
va a aumentar esta longitud va a
aumentar más que lo que disminuyó este
precio y por tanto tenemos que el
ingreso total aumenta es decir el área
el área aumentó porque uno de los lados
lo aumentamos proporcionalmente más que
el otro y esto casi siempre hace que el
ingreso total aumente muy bien ahora
vamos a pasar a un segundo punto vamos a
pasar o sea literalmente a un segundo
punto al punto digamos p2p 2 y acá le
corresponde déjame trazar la línea que
si no no me ubico entonces algo así y
aquí le corresponde un segundo punto q 2
pues aquí está con 2 ahora tenemos un
segundo ingreso total un ingreso total 2
que corresponde a esta área de acá vale
corresponde a esta área de acá y ahora
pensemos que en este punto de acá la
elasticidad de la demanda la elasticidad
de la demanda es menor que 1 entonces
ahora qué sucede pues fíjate una vez más
bueno aquí tenemos menor que 1 aquí
tendríamos menor que 1 entonces en esta
situación
ahora tenemos que se invierte esta
desigualdad es decir el valor absoluto
del cambio porcentual en q va a ser
menor que el valor absoluto del cambio
porcentual en p entonces ahora qué
sucede si en este punto de acá digamos
aumentamos la cantidad o disminuimos el
precio bueno podemos pensar ambas pero
qué pasa si aumentamos la cantidad si
nos vamos más a la derecha si aumentamos
la cantidad del cambio porcentual en cu
pues vale cierta cosa pero el cambio
porcentual en p que es hacia abajo por
la ley de la demanda verdad va hacia
abajo por la ley de la demanda ahora es
mayor entonces estamos disminuyendo el
precio más que lo que aumentamos la
cantidad y por tanto esta área de acá se
va a ser menor usualmente ahorita te voy
a explicar por qué usualmente porque
usualmente eso es mucho más claro en el
punto
el medio entonces vamos a ver ese de acá
cuando tenemos elasticidad unitaria
entonces pensamos que aquí tenemos un
precio 3 algo en este estilo y que por
acá tenemos una cantidad 3 deja mini
carlo así en cantidad 3 precio 3
aquí tenemos ingreso total 3 que es esta
área de acá entonces qué sucede aquí si
la elasticidad de la demanda es igual a
1 pues si la elasticidad de la demanda
es igual a 1 entonces ahora esta
desigualdad es una igualdad entonces
ahora tendríamos que el cambio
porcentual en q es igual al cambio
porcentual en p través se me estaba
escapando el cambio cambio porcentual en
p y por tanto que sucede pues como que
justo se compensa verdad sea justo
estamos haciendo un cambio en cuba pero
tenemos el mismo cambio porcentual en p
y entonces qué le pasa el área pues
cambiamos una cosa y luego que hagamos
una cosa equivalente entonces queda lo
mismo
bueno casi lo mismo déjame ahora sí
explicar por qué es casi lo mismo y no
exactamente lo mismo entonces para eso
vamos a ver un ejemplo para unos este
para acá entonces pensemos pensemos que
no sé qué aumenta
el precio el precio 3 en 10% entonces
déjame ponerlo por aquí vamos a ponerle
que el precio 3 pasa a ser si aumenta en
10% entonces el precio 3 pasa a ser 1.1
veces el precio 3 verdad eso es aumentar
en 10 por ciento le estamos aumentando
punto 1 de p3 y luego la cantidad 3 la
cantidad 3 como la elasticidad es
unitaria la cantidad 3 disminuye en 10%
el mismo cambio porcentual que acá
arriba entonces pasa a ser 0.9
q3 entonces qué sucede cuando hacemos
este cambio de 10% en esta región de acá
nuestro ingreso total inicialmente era
de 3 por 3 pero ahora pasa a ser este
producto de acá 1.1 por punto 9 pues es
lo mismo que 1.1 por 9 entre 10 verdad
entonces ahora tenemos este 0.99 cierto
es esto de acá de 3
p 3 por 3 entonces no es precisamente
que se quede igualito el ingreso total
pero queda casi igual de modo similar en
estos otros dos casos no es como que
siempre siempre quede mayor pero casi
siempre queda mayor o menor según si el
bien es elástico o bien si es inelástico
entonces esa es la idea eso es así está
relacionado el ingreso total y la
elasticidad y por tanto pues el ingreso
total como que justo se hace óptimo
cuando la elasticidad es unitaria una
vez más la mejor forma de entender esto
es con arias cuando el bien es elástico
el cambio porcentual aumenta verdad
bueno el cambio porcentual de la
cantidad es mayor que lo que bajamos de
precio el área aumenta cuando es
unitario más o menos es lo mismo y queda
casi igual y finalmente si el bien es
inelástico el cambio porcentual de la
cantidad es menor que el del precio y
por tanto el área en este caso disminuye